So let me start.
Um,
I'm going to read you something and you
have to guess what kind of a scene I'm
describing.
A ghostly stillness
descended over the country,
this country today with every restaurant,
bar and tea house in the country,
close every store,
shuttered and police patrolling the
streets to make sure no citizen day or to
step outside
avenues normally clogged with traffic
were so empty that picnics could have been
held on them except that nobody would
have been allowed to attend plazas that
are perpetual nightmares
of congestion and exhaust.
Exhaust fumes were abandoned to wandering
dogs and cats was also a good day for
the fish because the thousands
of fishermen who lined
the shorelines on Sunday,
we're all at home.
The waterway itself,
one of the world's busiest waterways
was this flat and silent as a woodland
pond. The government to
create a six month term jet,
a jail term for any citizen who
did not spend the day at home.
All in all the country today looked like
a land on which a neutron bomb had been
dropped, devastating the population
while leaving the buildings on damaged.
What do you think it
is? It's drastic. Yeah.
Like nope. Good, reasonable gas,
but no governments weren't as strong.
Then
it's a census day in Turkey.
Some places take their sentences very
seriously and require that people really
be in the place of their residents so
that they can be counted and that they get
a very good set of numbers and the
waterway that they're talking about
between Turd Europe and Asia
running through the boss spruce.
Right,
okay.
Now compare this to another country and
educated and motivated guy got one of
the temporary jobs as a census taker.
He was Chi class enough to get an article
published in the Atlantic monthly.
This is New York City, I'll
tell you, cause you'll get from,
he was six foot four and Caucasian.
They sent him to Chinatown.
People took one look at
him and slammed the door.
Others offered him money to go away.
Even most of those who tried to cooperate
did not have time to fill out the long
form.
He asked to be assigned to another area.
He got Wall Street. Same Story.
No one would cooperate with him.
He couldn't even get into one building.
But this was a motivated guy.
I was like a yellowy. So we climbed
onto the roof of the next building,
the building next door. He jumped over
the partition, not across the street,
but over the partition and uh,
to get into the building
that he was supposed to take.
The sense of self right there on
the roof was a dilapidated shack.
Okay. Maybe someone's living in the
shack. So he knocks on the door.
Someone inside flings
open the door inside.
He could see several apparently
naked people lying on hospital.
Gurneys the man who opened the
door was wearing a white coat,
go away.
He screamed.
I'm giving my wife a cancer
treatment New York City,
so I'm more,
I'm more experienced.
Census taker told him that
he wasn't doing it right.
What you have to do is what
they say kerbstone it. Uh,
and what that means is you sit on the
sidewalk and guess how many apartments are
in the building.
You look up at the building,
you guess how many apartments in the
building and fill out that many forms with
guesses about how many people
live in each apartment.
That's the way census that was done in
New York City, a comparison to Turkey.
Now these are describing the 1990 census.
So get to the 2000 census and a moment
that census was the most expensive ever.
It missed more than 2 million children,
of course, mostly minority children.
And imagine what this does
for school planning and it's
and et Cetera, et cetera.
It missed altogether,
not counting just children,
10 million people and a double
counted or counted in the wrong place.
Another 6 million people.
So between censuses,
the census peer uses the counter,
the last senses to make its projections.
They know the population is increasing
every year. How much do we have now? Now,
now and so. By the time they came
from the 1992 the 2000 census,
there were 7 million more
people in America than the
Census Bureau thought there
was. Population had been
increasing something like one
and a half times with what
they had thought it was.
So there's this slop matter,
the poor, the poor quality
of the United States census.
Well nowadays these numbers might seem
small but more than $185 billion a year
in federal aid to states are apportioned
according to the census results.
So every state's state really wants
its people counted. And on top of that,
what else is apportioned?
Depending on the Census Congress,
the House of Representatives
is apportioned.
So people want their estate to have
as many representatives as possible.
So given the importance of this, why is
it so bad? Why is the US census so bad?
The answers primarily politics,
it is well known,
big are the kinds of problems that this
census taker had in New York is very
well known and it's well known that these,
you know,
people that are considered
somewhat marginal minorities,
immigrants, poor people,
they are heavily under counted.
This is, this is well known.
The problem is that these
people don't vote Republican.
And when this story can aren't
telling you what takes place,
the Republicans control the
House of Representatives,
which controls the budget.
And so the census has
been missing this eight,
10 million for the 90 census,
8 million for before roughly eight
to 10 million people. And again,
it's these minority groups,
minorities, renters, urban dwellers,
and so democrats and they generally vote
Democrat and the Democrats have been
pushing, uh, to get them counted
to make an accurate account.
But a Republican redistricting as expert
wrote a memorandum in 1997 protecting
that adjustment could cross the
Republican Party 24 house seats,
which is a huge amount.
So since then,
the Republicans have blocked
any modernization of the census.
So for the year 2000 census,
uh,
President Clinton appointed a new
director of the Census Bureau and a woman
named Martha Reesh,
who we've had here at Yale and she
came out of a scientific and research
environment and was really very competent
scholar. I knew how to do it right.
And she announced when
she came into office,
all industrial democracies will be
holding a census in the year 2000.
We want the United States to
win a gold medal for accuracy.
She thought she was smart.
In fact,
of course she missed the boat because
she thought she was supposed to make an
accurate census and no,
that wasn't what she was hired for.
So what she proposed was a
statistical way of dealing with this.
You know, the groups that you've
missed, you know where they live.
So after you've countered everyone as
well as you can on the whole country,
you go back to the inner
city neighborhoods,
the various places where you know that
you're going to miss people and you
really blanket that and do that.
Those areas very carefully,
a sample across the country.
And then you find out what your errors
are in that large sample and then you can
adjust the whole population, assuming
you made the same mistakes everywhere.
And she was very open. That's
what she planned to do. And uh,
at the time though, a Newt Gingrich, I
don't know if you know that name with, uh,
the, uh, what is it?
The new deal for America or something
I was in was the speaker of the house
controlled the budget
and he said, um, Yep,
you have the authority to do that.
You're the director of the budget,
but if you do that, I will cut
your budget to zero. Basically. Uh,
she wasn't allowed to do that.
And so she had to resign.
She just would not do a census.
That was, that was less than what,
what we are capable of doing.
Uh,
so the census was done
the old fashioned way.
It costs one point $7 billion more than
it would have with sampling and was not
anywhere near as accurate.
Now these same considerations
apply almost everywhere.
So in China for instance,
uh,
you know about the one child policy and
the government is strongly trying to
push the birth rate down.
We'll talk about this later in,
in much more detail.
And so a provincial official
gets the word. This is,
we want your population growth rate to
be no more than whatever percentage.
And then he sends it down
to the prefecture and down.
Do you think any of these officials
after the census are going to send up
information that they have
not been doing their job?
That the birth rate is higher?
No. So there's problems with that.
Who collects this data?
Well,
luckily several or many
organizations collect the data,
but primarily the UN who owns the UN
member countries. And if you, uh,
if you are, say a conservative
religious country and if,
uh, the UN demographer says that contrary
to government statistics that there
actually is a high rate of illegitimacy
or abortion in the country.
All of which comes out of
the, of, of the statistics,
they're not going to allow that,
that to be published.
So the UN has to sort of cut some
corners so that the countries from who is
dependent on to get the data,
we'll continue to send them the data.
In addition,
even when a country tries,
there are something like 50 million birth
registration is not done everywhere in
the world. And there's something like 50
million babies worldwide who were never
registered. They don't exist
on the official, uh, registers.
So when you try to do what
demographers do, you have account,
you have a count of a census in one year,
you have account of a census in a later
year in between you have a list of
births and deaths,
supposedly both births,
the registered and deaths are registered
and you see, is this reasonable,
you know,
is the difference accounted for by births,
deaths and migration if you have
reasonable amounts of migration, uh,
but if millions of the babies
are just not registered,
you can't check things that way.
So there's a lot of,
lot of problems.
Um,
another thing is that in
many, many countries, uh,
there's conflict between different groups.
We've talked about democratic
Republican, uh, in the United States,
in Nigeria,
in Sudan,
there's a huge conflict between the
Muslim populations in the north and the
Christian, uh, or animus
populations in the south.
You may or may not recall the,
they'd be off for a war in Nigeria,
a huge war between basically over oil,
but between the Muslim north
and the Christian south, uh,
millions of deaths and millions of deaths
now currently in Sudan over something
of a similar issue.
And so in census,
in ethnically or religiously
split countries are taken.
The key event is the ratio.
The key outcome that everybody wants
to know is the ratio between how many
Christians, how many Muslims, how
many this, how many, how many of that.
And so,
uh,
the censuses get totally distorted by
people trying to raise their numbers and
lower everyone else's numbers. So, uh,
before the br for war,
there was apparently a reasonably accurate
census in 1952 to 1953 then the BF
war intervened and the next several
sentences were very controversial.
So the accepted official
figures in Nigeria,
we're 88 and a half million people,
but the World Bank said,
no, that's wrong. Hundred
and 2 million people. Uh,
the United Nations,
120 million people.
So basically for a country as big and as
important as Nigeria for their, their,
their last census,
we have figures range between 88
and a half million and 120 million,
a 50% uncertainty for Nigeria.
So big.
Uh,
the point of this initial part,
0.1 is that even the simplest
numbers like headcounts,
we're not doing anything fancy.
We're just trying to count how many people
there are. One, two, three, four, five.
There are systematic errors and very
often those errors are intentional.
Okay.
Now
all of these numbers,
well I say when I described these numbers,
and I probably won't do it enough
when I put up a demographic number,
it should almost always
being qualified by,
and there are large and
unknown error bars here,
but we don't have aerobars for it.
So various organizations collect all this
data and this is called the population
reference bureau,
which is a source of statistics and news.
Everything about population.
And it's a very big sheet here.
I'll show it to you,
blown up. And it has every region,
the world, every country of the world,
and a large number of demographic
statistics for each of these countries.
So let's
look at one of these.
So yeah,
here is
one page of this sheet. Can
you see that? Well enough,
I don't need to pick away.
And what you see is this is the
various numbers that they count.
Population birth rate,
death rate,
rate of increase migration rate in or out,
um,
plus for coming in out for going out what
their projected population is for 2025
or 2050 and so forth.
Down there.
A number that we'll try to get to describe
later called the total fertility rate,
which is more or less the number of
children and women are expecting are we'll
have as they go through their lifetime.
And then on this side,
it's broken down first into the world,
broken down by level of development
than by geographic region.
So a lot of really a very good data,
very clearly put on here.
And you can look first at
the world's population here.
So that's the first
number in the whole thing.
This is the middle of 2008 so there was
6.7 billion people on earth and still
rising.
The expectation for mid 2025 is 8 billion,
and for 20,
59.3 or 4 billion.
Those are guesses about the future.
And I'll tell you maybe
a little bit about how,
how those are done.
Um,
okay,
look now
at the birth rate here.
So this is births per thousand population
and the birth rate of the world, uh,
is, is 21 and we're going to go
crazy going back and forth there. Um,
so how accurate is that? Uh, again,
we don't know large and uncertain aerobars
it's something like a third of the
children in the world that don't
have proper birth certificates.
So you can't know whether they've,
they've encountered at all.
So another thing you should
notice about the way it gets,
what he's not only the world
when it breaks it down into
development categories,
uh,
there's less developed countries that
includes China and less developed
countries excluding China.
It's important to get those two things
different because China is considered
very exceptional.
One because of it's one child policy
and they think that the birth rate is
abnormally depressed. And two, it's
tremendous rate of economic development.
So if you want a real characterization
of the less developed countries, uh,
even though China is average income is
very low, it's changing very rapidly,
then you do it without China and
you get a different numbers there.
Um,
look next
at the birth rate for whoops.
Okay.
That was keeping the birth rate.
The birth way for the whole world is 21
per thousand per year and the birth rate
for the less developed is 23.
Not a big difference.
Why is that? How come so close?
Whereas for the developed countries,
it's 12.
Why is the birth rate for the world
so close to the less developed?
Right.
The overwhelming majority
of the population is in the
less developed countries.
So whatever we understand
about that, that is, uh,
what we have to, uh, that is
characteristic of, of the world.
Um,
so
this chain, this difference
in birth rate between say 12,
in the more developed countries and uh,
say 23,
26, even 36 for the least developed
countries, that is a huge difference.
It's a factor of three between the
most developed and the least developed.
And in fact you have something like
two and a half over two in between,
which means that now most of the world
is in the underdeveloped countries,
most of the population. And that will
continue and we'll get more extreme.
So here is an example of that.
This is,
we're now talking about here and the
more developed regions like the US or are
still growing very slightly,
but basically going to be flat as
far as one can project out here.
But the less developed countries are
undergoing this population explosion.
So if the ratio between the less developed
countries and the develop regions is
this now, that will only
increase after, I'm sorry,
2050 out here.
So this,
that the world is demographically
characterized by the
poor countries is a fact
now in a much better fact as time goes on,
more a more complete fact.
So that's the first point is about
the accuracies of statistics.
The second one here is that
it's not the develop countries.
When you think of what's
happening in world population,
don't think of the developed countries.
What's happened,
what's happening is what's happening
in the underdeveloped countries of the
developing countries.
Now let's shift and
look at the death rate.
We've looked a little at the birth
rate and you notice something,
furnishing. Here's the birth
rate. And we've just been
saying for the whole world,
uh, 21, uh, per thousand per year.
Look at the death rate eight.
That means there's more than two
and a half times in the world.
Now there's more than two and a half
times as many births as there are deaths
and enormous difference.
And you can compare in the
less developed regions,
there's something like three times
as many births as there are deaths,
nine deaths,
26 births.
So there's a huge right now,
there's a huge imbalance between the
births and the deaths and as you know,
population stability,
which many people think would be a good
thing for the world. Uh, it depends on uh,
the deaths and the births being equal,
which means that the
world is out of kilter.
The ratio between births and deaths
is now out of kilter by a factor of
something like two and a half to three,
two and a half of the whole world,
three for the developing countries.
And what that means is either the death
rate has to come up to that level or the
birth rate has to come
down or some combination.
Part of this is where we'll
see three, what's going to
happen with part of it, uh,
in a bit later. So the, the,
the major point of this is that the
world is very far from population
stabilization.
You've probably heard lots in the news
about declining birth rates in Europe and
Japan and so forth.
And our next lecture will be about
that will be just about that.
But it's not characteristic of the world.
The world is way out,
way out of balance.
And even in the United States,
which is one of the few developing
countries, uh, that still, uh,
having a population increase,
we have 14 births for every eight deaths,
and that's one in three quarters times,
uh, the number of births as death.
So the United States is way out of
whack and that's births versus that that
doesn't include immigration includes the
children of immigrants that are born in
this country but doesn't
include immigration. So hour,
hour bursts plus immigration is going
to be at least double our birth rate.
So our population is, uh, also, uh,
not anywhere near balanced.
Okay. Now, unlike the birth rate,
which is very different in
different parts of the world,
the death rate is not extraordinarily
different. So here it's,
I see you squinting, is it, can
you see it well enough? Well,
the death rate in the developed
country is 10 per thousand.
And in the less developed
countries, again, without
Trynna, it's nine per thousand.
A very small difference.
And the reason for that is,
is that mortality has formed
because of vaccination programs,
especially vaccination programs.
Oral Rehydration for diarrhea and a lot
of very basic public health matters.
Not Open heart surgery
or anything like that,
but the most basic public health
measures has, has dropped, uh,
the death rate in the world tremendously.
Again,
especially the infant death rate sub
Saharan Africa is somewhat of an exception
to that. So, uh, did you met anybody?
Remember maybe you studied it.
I think what I said was sort of a,
a premodern death rate.
Somebody said it, I think
they said it right, 40,
about 40 per thousand.
And now it's down to one quarter of that,
which is a modern rate and
it's not going to decrease, uh,
in a, in an enormous amount more. And so,
uh, fertility. So the
changes in the death,
when you look about the
future of population,
further changes in the death rate will
have some effect, but not an enormous, uh,
effect. It's, it's changing
the fertility rate,
the whole future world population depends
essentially on the fertility rate.
Little bit from a change in the death
rate, somewhat from people aging,
but primarily fertility rate is what
you watched to find out what's going to
happen in the future of rural population.
Unless of course you can.
We have atom bombs or something
like that and everybody dies. Now,
as an example of this, uh, uh, um,
deaf flatness of the death
rate, this is from Egypt. Uh,
this, this is a lovely graph. Notice
the little baby in swaddling clothes.
I pulled that.
This is from the Egyptian statistical
abstract though the Egyptian published
this themselves and
it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's not the most reason that goes up to
about 1990 and maybe now they've gotten
more computerized. Don't dress the
things that, but I just liked that.
And the color in that color is the
original color in the original statistical
report.
So notice the number of births
increasing continuously with,
with some small dip here,
but basically it goes from a thousand
to this up here would be 2000 in this
period of time,
the birth rate nearly doubles.
And this is absolute number of people,
not a percentage,
but look what happens to the death rate.
Very little change in the death rate
starting way back in 1952 so way before,
a lot of very modern kind of medical
stuff. So it's basic medical, uh,
basic public health, basic sanitation
that that's responsible for this. So now,
so the number of deaths and
staying more or less constant.
And of course the natural increase,
the increase in population is the
difference between births and deaths.
So you have an increasing every year you
get more and more population increase.
This is the population explosion.
You've seen numbers like that.
Now, uh, is the death
rate staying constant?
No,
the death rate,
not saying because the population is
increasing and yet you're having the same
number of deaths. So
the percentage of, uh,
of the population that's dying each
year is going down slowly, not at a,
at a,
as a percentage of it is a slow decrease
over this time period and continuing
the death rate is decreasing but not
in a significant enough to make a big
difference in the total
population growth statistics.
So,
uh,
the basic thing in the world is that the
fertility rate is what a chain going to
what can change a lot,
can make the difference between a
moral truth population keeps growing or
stabilizes or starts
at decreasing. Now, uh,
anybody notice anything funny so far?
The one number that should have known one
pair of numbers that should have what?
Let's go back to that.
Anything funny about these numbers?
Yeah, so the less developed
countries have a lower birth rate,
then the more developed countries,
Ooh,
not surprising that their health systems
or their health is better than ours.
Let's just check that number
and let's look at, for instance,
in compare the United States
with our neighbor Mexico.
We know Mexico is much poorer and
probably doesn't have as good of kind of
system.
Well,
here's our deaths per thousand in
United States is eight Mexico five.
It's good. It's a good bit
less than we have. And further,
here's Central America.
There's not a single country
that's as high as we are.
Every single one.
The Central Mountain Curry,
I'm putting some pretty poor countries.
El Salvador has a lower death
rate than the United States,
and Mexico is kind of in the middle
between the four and the six striking.
You go further afield.
Here's the Caribbean and these
are more in the range of a Vus,
oops. Of, of, of the U s level. But there,
the u s is not better than almost
any of them except for Haiti.
Haiti is the only place that has a
nose bleed. Worse death rate than us.
What?
Yes. Yes. These are total
death rates. Once you're born.
If you die after you're born,
your accounting don't,
don't include a spontaneous
or induced abortions.
Okay. So, uh, we got a problem here.
What do you think is the reason for this
loud, loud state some
more over there. People,
exactly.
The United States has more older people,
and it's a funny thing about older people.
They're the ones who tend to die.
Once you've got rid of your
infant mortality issue,
people tend to die at the older ages.
That's exactly correct.
And it's an extreme in an, in a developed
country. It's an extreme difference.
Here's what's left. So this the United
States, this is the deaths per thousand,
the age of the people. And here's
what's left of the infant mortality.
It's still more dangerous to be an infant
than, than later, but there's virtually,
you can't even see the death
rate through the middle years.
But then boom, it goes up as
you get on into the older ages.
So indeed the death rate is completely
sensitive to your age distribution that a
country that has more young people
will have a lower death rate.
A country that has a high birth rate,
we'll have more young people
will have a lower death rate.
So what you're seeing
in that anomaly there,
what looked like an anomaly is basically
that Mexico has a higher birth rate of
people. And this funny thing that you
happened to be born young and you die old.
And so that is the explanation for that.
So any time,
any,
almost any demographic number that
you want to interpret, marriage rates,
birth rates,
death rates of fertility rates,
almost everything of interest is
affected by the age distribution and
understanding demographics,
statistics,
the most important thing is
always the age distribution.
And so you always have
to pay attention to that.
And later on I'll show you one of the
mechanisms for paying attention for
getting statistics, uh, adjusting
statistics for the age distribution.
Okay?
But how first let's just look at it.
So here is the easiest way of
looking at an age distribution.
What you have here, this is for
Germany and the pink is the old,
this is 1989 when eastern
west Germany are still split.
So this is the German Democratic Republic,
East Germany.
The pink is East Germans and the
dark is the, is the federal public,
the western money.
And on the left is a man and
on the right is his female,
male and female.
Whoops.
And what this graphs is that every year.
So this is age zero and you're
just born to age a hundred.
What is this
age?
A hundred that every year
they ask how many people are,
how many kids are there between age zero
and one where there's so many males and
so many females. This number in eastern
Germany, this number in western.
And so you can go through every age
and just count from your census,
the number of people at that age and draw
it out like this. And it's a wonderful,
huge amount of information. In a single
graph. You can see all kinds of things.
Look, this is world war one. The
people born during World War One,
they're almost all all go on.
But here's the ones from World War
Two and look at the big difference.
Here's your females, here's your
mails. What's the difference?
War deaths,
right?
The men are in the army and they
get chewed up on the Russian front.
So you have many more females than males.
It's partially that women live older also.
But this case in Germany
is almost exclusive, is,
is overwhelmingly the deaths
from World War One hears.
There's still some females,
there's no males. Uh,
and then the deaths from World War Two,
you can see the birth deficit.
These are people who would have
been born during World War One.
These were adults fighting age
adults during World War One.
These would have been born,
well, the men were away. Uh,
so they didn't have any babies. They had
very few babies during World War One.
And the same thing you see
for World War World War Two.
And you'll see again the deficits of uh,
you know,
while where we talked about that.
So you can see that.
Then you can see there's a postwar baby
boom that after the deficit in World War
II, people make up for it. And more
than make up the, for the deficit.
So you have this huge bulge in population,
uh,
both males and females,
but now balanced more or less
equal numbers of males and females.
And then you get the baby bust
and you get a little echo effect.
So that there's very,
a fluctuations in a puppet.
Almost every country has a western country
has these kind of data plus the Asian
countries that were involved in world
war two. So you can see that. See it's a,
it's a, it's a wonderful way
of, of understanding a country.
Now
this is India
and the census of India.
That's a weird one.
What the heck is going on there?
Yeah,
that's weird. So what it is is
people don't know their ages.
There are numerous and so it gets
counted every five or 10 years.
So he has a five year or 10 year period.
They know their ages approximately
two proximately a certain year.
They don't know what exactly.
It's not important in a, in a,
in a pre industrial country, the exact
age is not all that terribly important.
So, uh, you get this, what that's called,
age heaping that when you get a
large excess in five or 10 year,
my own father who was an immigrant,
I did not know his age. There was,
he was born either 1904 and 1907
cause he even had a birth certificate,
but it was in the Russian cyrillic
character and the four looks like a seven.
So he, he and my mother argued
constantly over how old he actually was.
And even countries that have had a long,
you know,
European have the same thing here
as the Soviet Union from there,
1937 census just, and here
again, you get this same age,
cheap and effect,
not quite as extreme as India,
but very clearly here and to a degree
worse with women than with men because
women are less educated.
See the big bars here,
the small bars here and in
principle it should be getting less.
With younger people it
should be a clearer,
and you certainly have to get rid
of these extreme, uh, uncertainties.
But it's not,
it's persisting into the 1930s.
This I don't know how old I am,
uh,
except within a five or 10 year bracket.
Okay.
And here's another Weirdo.
What's that?
Just to show you that you can immediately,
once you get used to this,
immediately tell an awful lot
about country from age pyramid.
Anybody from Arizona?
Nobody.
It's Sun City,
Arizona,
which is a retirement community
and they don't allow anybody,
I think most of these have a, an age
limit of 50 if you have to be at least 55.
So this is the retirement age and where
my mother lives in, in certain village,
in West Palm Beach, looks like
the Florida, looks like that. Uh,
various retired and California has
retirement villages. They look like that.
So these population pyramids are wonderful
with lots of information packed into
this and from seeing these pyramids,
uh,
you can tell a lot, uh, about, um,
yeah,
all right.
You can tell a lot about the socioeconomic
character of the countries because we
know that the poor countries have less
literacy and et Cetera, et Cetera,
and they have higher birth
rates. And so we look at, uh,
what that looks like right now.
So here is uh,
two of these population pyramids
and here is you saw on those,
the splitting of the world
to more developed regions
and less developed regions.
And what do you notice right away,
the total area under this,
so this is now five year age.
He travels and single year,
so between zero and four is
this amount or this amount?
So it's the area under this is how
many total people there are. So one,
you see this a lot less area here is a
lot less people that the less developed
regions where the or
the bulk of the world,
but also the shape is very different here
in the developed regions you have more
or less similar,
uh,
a number of people in all ages.
It's not exactly that way.
Of course at the old ages of people are
dying and that starts about here and
there in the 50s and then accelerates and
this very few less so it narrows here.
And also it's narrowing
down here because the,
the birth rate in the developed
countries is now below replacement level.
Uh,
and so the pyramid are getting to be fewer
people in the younger ages than there
are older people.
Contrast that with less
developed parts of the world.
And you see that there's
more and more younger people,
each age cohort has more and more people.
You can look at an individual country,
and this is a clearer example.
This isn't Nigeria as far as we can
tell from their sentences, but they,
you can tell an age distribution and this
is now present rather than total from
from sub samples.
You don't need to count aptly everybody
to understand what the age distribution
is and here is a 50 year change.
There's not one,
it's not changing very much.
This is what it was in 1975 they know
more or less what it is now and they're
projecting it out to 2000 I'm sorry,
2005 this is a pretty current and it
looks about the same and vastly as you go
in this case as you go to
younger and younger people,
vastly more children than older folks.
So what's happening here can
see what the ages are here.
15 especially in Nigeria,
15 to 45 these are the ages in which
women are giving birth and this number of
women is giving birth to
more than two children.
They're more than replacing themselves.
So each bar is bigger than the less,
and some of this in swing, especially
since this is in sub Saharan Africa,
some of this reduction is infant
mortality and child mortality.
Some of the different specialties in
this bar and this bar that's in there,
but it's a small effect.
The major effect is that every generation
is bigger and they produce more and
more children here.
Um, now, uh,
let's see.
So when you look at how,
what's going to evolve in the future,
so here is your women who are
40 to 45, that's this, this punch
of when women and women on this.
So that's the number of women they're
producing part of these children in
another five years. If you
look at this, five years later,
these women who were 40 to 45 are
now 45 to 50. No more fertility,
pretty much there Nigeria,
and not using a lot of IVF and everything.
So they have stopped reproducing.
But that cohort of that size is being
replaced by the ones of this size coming
into fertile ages.
So women that were 10 to 15 are becoming
15 and 20 and starting their child
bearing when women that are 40 to 45
which have not so much childbearing left
are going out of existence
stopping childbearing. Absolutely.
So the number of women, the number of
child bearers is increasing drastically.
In this case it looks, you know, Ballpark,
like there are twice as many women coming
into reproductive age as are leaving
reproductive age each each year, each
five years, however you want to count it.
So the number of childbearing
women is increasing tremendously.
And the result of that is uh,
here's another comparison.
Whereas in the West, in,
in developed countries,
you know the number of 40 to 45 year olds
and not enormously different than the
number to 15 to 19.
So the women that are leaving reproductive
ages are more or less replaced by the
women that are coming into reproductive
ages. Of course with population decline,
eventually you get fewer women coming
into reproductive age in developed
countries that are leaving it so
that you have fewer child bearers.
So this phenomenon can, if you're,
if you're popular, is increasing,
the problem gets more and more severe.
If it's decreasing,
There's a positive feedback on this
with your number of child bearers,
either growing or decreasing.
Now,
so here is, uh, in
Billy and the number of,
of women of childbearing age in the
world and it just keeps increasing.
Right? What, uh, you may be aware of,
I haven't really talked about this much.
Yes,
it's in my next lecture here
is the birth rate in the world,
children per women.
So the birth rate has been coming down.
So two opposite things are
happening in the world.
The number of childbearing
women is going up,
but the number of children that each of
them has is going down and they predict
optimistically that by 2050,
it will reach about replacement level,
about two children per women. But
it's not there. We're not there yet.
We're almost double. Uh,
I'm sorry. We're, uh,
we're, we're, we're way above that now.
So the result of this
number of women rising,
their rate of child bearing decreasing
is that the number of births,
you sort of multiplied those two out.
The number of births is expected
to continue increasing for the,
for for the predictable future.
So that's an absolute number of births
will increase as a result of these two
crossing factors.
So now the birth rate is
coming down and it eventually,
let's presume in the future, gets to
be too children. What then happens,
you still have a pyramid like this,
but now it starts flattening out,
but it flattens out. Let's
see, I should do this by hand.
In fact,
I want to go to this graph shows this.
This is what's actually predicted
to happen. So this is again,
developing countries and this is
the kind of pyramid that we've seen.
This one goes back to 1985 with
this broadly increasing thing.
It's basically a triangle, right? You
can think of it as a triangle. Now,
if immediately now god sticks
his finger out of heaven.
It says two children and even more
surprising people obey him. What happens,
this is the number of children,
people that there are there that
the population pyramid will grow up,
but with this as a base so
that it will become square,
but there'd be this many people,
so you go from a triangle to a
rectangle with the same base.
Can you see that thing?
The number of people is the area
inside that and you had the same base.
You go from a triangle to rectangle.
Remember from high school
geometry what the area is,
it doubles because if you have
a triangle and you go square,
you just slipped the tea that half the
triangle over and you've got that many
people again.
So if a miracle happens and fertility
stops dead right now and we go immediately
to two to children per women,
the population doubles
before it stabilizes, right?
What this shows you is that of course
it's that miracle is not going to happen.
This is quite optimistic and is already
not not the case that the base will also
increase.
Since population is still increasing,
the base will increase and yes it will
get more rectangular but even by 2025 it
won't yet be rectangular so that you
will on this kind of production more than
double the population from 1985 because
the base is growing as well as your,
you're rising up and so there's an
expectation of quite a lot of population
increase who left this whole
phenomenon where because you,
once you start having an increasing
population, uh, you're going to,
the population is going to keep
increasing because there's more and more
childbearers unless something drastic
happens to the fertility rate is called
population momentum cause you sort
of moving in a certain direction of
increasing population,
it just continues in.
The same thing happens as you'll hear
next lecture with population decreasing.
Then when population decreases you
have fewer and fewer child bearers in,
each generation has to say
Japan now or Singapore.
And so unless the birth
rate increases tremendously,
you'll have fewer and fewer children.
And what this shows you is that if
there was immediate replacement,
this kind of miracle, that
everything, everything,
everybody comes to just two
children immediately, then uh,
the population would be this.
So this effect is all momentum.
All of this increase from where we are
now to up here is just a momentum effect.
Just the fact that there's more and more
and more children coming into age and
that takes a very long time to work out.
And then the fact that there's in fact a,
they're not going
immediately to two children,
not immediate immediate replacement.
This is the United Nations guests
as to what's going to happen.
The actual population is
projected to go like this.
So to chill, if everybody
immediately goes to two children,
you get this population rise.
What is actually expected is somewhat
more so huge amount of what's happening
with population. Future is
already determined. It's
already momentum is in there.
And even if birth rates
really come down very rapidly,
the world's population is
going to continue increasing.
Okay. So that's, that's sort of the,
an important thing to remember in
the world of fertility is decreasing.
The population is increasing.
Uh, and those are not canceling out. Um,
so
from 1985, the prediction was at the
world population with someone double,
we've made some progress between there,
but still we have 6.7 billion now and the
expectation is something like 50% more
people on Earth in 2050 and
perhaps continuing to increase,
uh,
beyond that,
almost a huge amount of
momentum effects here is,
uh,
well let me go back.
This is Maureen [inaudible]
and islands in the,
in the Indian Ocean and it's one of
the examples of a small underdeveloped
country that had a very
surprising fertility decline.
So this, uh, this is,
this is probably the
influenza epidemic here,
but starting in around right after
war two in the, in the late 1940s,
it's death rate fell down.
Modern public health
comes in to Mauritius.
So the death rate falls dramatically.
Then this fits the standard,
uh, characteristic of the
demographic transition.
About 20 years later, about one
generation later, people learn what,
we don't have to have so many children
because they're not dying and the birth
rate comes down thereafter.
So,
uh,
and population growth is in here.
So this is a country that did well,
that starting fairly early for a,
uh,
for a developing country in 1951 say
their birth rate is falling down.
They, they really, uh,
sort of got it under control and,
but you look at this, so, uh,
this is the, uh, uh, the birth,
the total fertility rate,
which is a birth rate here in the stays
stable and then it starts falling down
quite, quite significantly. But look
at, here's the total population size.
You don't even see a change.
Well, momentum. So here, the,
the birth rate has
started dropping in 1965,
and now we're 25 years later and you
don't see hardly any change in the
population growth rate.
That's what we talked about by the
momentum effect that because at this time,
before they dropped their fertility at,
at this time,
there were so many more children than
older people that the number of women
childbearers just keeps, it kept
increasing and increasing, increasing.
So even though fertility drops, uh,
the number of children's stays high,
even gets higher and the
population just keeps increasing.
It's a very, very strong effect
and the number of, and it's not,
not flattened out there yet,
25 years later.
This is a projection of how long
does it take before it flattens out.
So this is,
uh,
the first one.
The first box is the year that this is
our current size as of whatever year.
This was by 23rd. This
in the United States, us,
this is the number of, of people. So, uh,
this graph was made in, uh, it
doesn't say the date, but our pop in,
we'll increase somewhat by 20,
30.
And this really is ignoring the
changes that have happened to this with
immigration and so forth that we will,
we reach two child.
Uh,
if our fertility comes down,
we reached to child in 2030
and we stabilized because
we have not had a rapidly
expanding puppies. So we stabilized
right away. Nigeria, which you,
you saw our current population,
it's supposed to been some optimistic
assumptions reach two children per women
in the year 2035,
but then it doesn't stabilize
until 115 years later at again,
a much increased population.
So in the case of Nigeria,
after it reaches to child per woman,
after it reaches replacement level,
it takes another hundred and 15 years
before population actually stabilizes.
This is Bangladesh, 125
years. This is Iran. Uh,
uh, 110 years, Ron has had a big
crash. We'll talk about that.
And it's populated with Brazil 145 years.
It takes an enormous amount of time,
uh,
for momentum to work itself out
after the fertility rate comes down.
So it's,
it's,
it's quite striking and that's the reason
why we expect so much more population
to happen. Again, you can
look at an individual country.
This is Algeria.
And look at, look at what Algeria
has done between now and 20 years.
That's an enormous rate.
Here's its crude birthrate.
It's crude means not
corrected for age or anything.
Just to take a thousand people.
How many babies were there
for that thousand people
and in 1965 it was 50 and it
dropped to 38 a very large drop and it's
a drop of 24% they cut their birth rate
and a quarter. That's 25% in 20
years. That's more than 1% a year.
There's a very, very rapid
change, but because of momentum,
the population growth rate was 2.4% in
1965 even though the birth rate is going
down,
the population growth rate is going up,
all momentum and the percentage change
that the growth rate and increased by 19%
in all of this because at this age they
had been having a population explosion,
so many more younger children than older.
The population almost doubled from 12
million to 22 million population went up
83% and the annual population growth
rate increased from a quarter million to
600000.6 million
change 217%.
So here's the dilemma for
developing countries that
basically all the developing
countries understand that they need that,
that economically there,
there'll be destroyed if there
population growth rate increases.
Virtually every developing country has
now an official national policy of trying
to get its birth rate down.
We'll see later that,
that that's okay with the people they're
generally in, in accord with this,
and they can do wonder. They
can do miracles. These country,
you'll see some of the drops next time
I'll talk about Nixon, my lecture,
I'll talk about some of the fabulous
drops. I mean, this is not exceptional.
This is a very, uh, very, uh, significant
drop, but it's not exceptional,
uh, around the world. And
yet even in the face of that,
that population goes up
into massive amounts.
83% up 100% of more than somewhat.
So as the government is
pushing modernization and as
the government is pushing,
uh,
reducing the birth rate and as grassroots
organizations to push the try to get
the birth rate down, the population keeps
increasing. And Industrial Development,
if it's not extremely rapid,
can't keep up with the birth rate.
So while these countries are modernizing,
they can see conditions deteriorate,
poverty can grow,
crowding can grow,
homelessness can grow
again because population,
even though you get your birth rate down,
your population keeps increasing.
So extremely.
And so some,
some theory believe that there's
kind of a window of opportunity for,
for developing countries that
uh, for instance, you take Egypt,
uh, which I'm sure it's also had
one of these drops, not unlike this,
they were the kings of the world, top
of the world in the Pharaoh's time know,
you'll know that kind of history.
Then iron was invented but not in Egypt.
And Egypt was in the bronze age.
During the pharaohs time.
Iron is invented maybe in Turkey
who I didn't know exactly where.
And the other people's, the world picked
up iron and made iron swords. And the,
the Egyptians for some reason
never really got on to iron.
Maybe they don't have any iron
anywhere there. And so from a,
from a hundred to 1000 BC
or something till 1950,
they were always subject to somebody else.
They're always ruled by
someone else until Nasser, uh,
gotten rid of the British.
In 1950,
they were ruled by the British and then
before that by the Turks and buy all
kinds of peoples. The Greeks
before, you know, at, uh,
Alexander the Great's time
and so forth in the Romans,
they're ruled by someone else.
So here comes, here's 1952,
I think NASA is revolution,
gets rid of the British,
sets up an independent republic.
The people are very enthusiastic
about this. They're very excited.
They're now throw off the shackles of
imperialism and colonialism and they can
now be their own country.
But the birth rate is still very high.
The population growth rate is very high.
They have to industrialize real fast.
They can't and they don't
industrialize that fast.
They don't modernize their
economy. Why? Whole lot of reasons.
One of which is they waste huge amounts
of money on the conflict with Israel
that they have war after war and have
to spend huge amounts of money on the
military that would be better spent,
uh, under economic development.
So time passes and the people
have tried to modernize.
That's been the ideology.
They tried socialists modernization,
they've tried capitalist modernization.
And what they see is
more and more crowding.
Poverty is not going away. Conditions
are not getting very much better. I mean,
they do get a little bit better,
but not terribly much better.
And so they give up on modernization
when they give up on modernization,
they glorify the past.
They say it was better in the past and
they go to a romantic attitude for what
it was like in and can try to reverse
modernization by resisting further drops
in birth rate. For instance,
going back to religion,
and when I was in Egypt some some years
back, went into sort of a restaurant.
They seat you sometimes at long tables.
So you know,
people you don't know you sit next to
and uh, if they happen to speak English,
which I could talk to them,
I don't speak Arabic.
And so the ones that I could talk to
her upper class educated people and
therefore upperclass people that spoke
fairly good English and you meet this a
nice young woman and she was,
uh, at the University of Cairo,
which is my lead school, uh, and
choose an engineering students.
So perfectly intelligent, perfectly
modern in that way, wearing a headscarf,
you know,
which her mother did not wear,
which was not in the previous
generation that she doesn't believe in
modernization.
Basically for her own self benefit,
she'll become an engineer
because she wants a decent job.
She doesn't want to have herself go back
and digging the digging the desert dirt
there to try to get some food. She wants
to be a modern person with a good job.
At least she wants a good job,
but she doesn't believe in modernization.
The rest of her ideology,
aside from her personal
desires is backward looking
that things were better in
the past. Modernization has not worked.
So this is, uh, exam, sort of this,
this window of opportunity
when a country's first
tried to get modernized and
one of the things that goes along with
modernization as the reduced fertility
rate, if it doesn't work,
people will reject that.
And a lot of what's going
on in the world today, uh,
with respect to the developed
and undeveloped countries
in the Arab countries in
the western countries has to do with this
rejection of modernization because it
did not work for them.
And with that,
if the birth rate stays high as it
has not in the Muslim countries,
many Muslim countries have
had fabulous progress.
It's been a lot of the Arab countries,
the birth rate has stayed very high and
there's these huge numbers of unemployed
young men, the economy cannot
absorb them. They're hanging around,
they're idealistic as, as well as young
men are. And what ideas do they pick up?
But going back to some imagined past
that was glorious and the world may hinge
on this window of opportunity,
how many countries can take advantage
of a China clearly took advantage of it.
Japan took advantage of a lot of the
East Asian countries took advantage of
their window of opportunity.
A lot of other countries did not take
advantage of their window of opportunity.